[Musik]
nein wir sind hier nicht in einem star
wars film gelandet sondern in einem
realen lichtschwert kampf
in dieser französischen turnhalle in
einem pariser vorort verwandeln sich
junge sportler in kämpfer der dunklen
seite der macht aus der star wars saga
hier dreht sich alles um star wars als
kind habe ich von star wars geträumt und
da von einem nicht schwer zu besitzen
und damit zu spielen wie in den filmen
egal wie alt man ist man kann damit spaß
haben wie im film lichtschwert fechten
ist ein trend in frankreich inspiriert
vom star wars universum was von us
regisseur george lucas geschaffen wurde
mittlerweile werden regelmäßig
lichtschwerter turniere organisiert und
antonie loco gilt als favorit er hat die
vergangenen beiden nationalen
meisterschaften gewonnen dieses mal
kämpft er mit fast 40 konkurrenten aus
ganz frankreich um den titel
[Musik]
gewinner ist wer nach drei minuten in
führung liegt oder 15 punkte erreicht
[Musik]
für einen treffer am kopf gibt es fünf
punkte für die beine 3 ein echter sport
findet machen das weil sie star wars
mögen
für andere ist die ästhetik wichtig oder
der sport für mich trifft eher letzteres
zu ich mag natürlich star wars aber
sport und disziplin sind mir wichtiger
eine der wenigen lichtschwert
fechterinnen ist amon dienen es gibt
nicht viele frauen aber die wenigen
frauen hier sie mit ganzem herzen dabei
und zeigen dass wir das auch können
lilo coco ist seit drei jahren
begeistert vom lichtschwert fechten ein
pionier der disziplin der französische
verband hat die sportart im mai 2018
offiziell anerkannt als erster und
einziger verband der welt
wir versuchen jugendliche zu begeistern
und das star wars universum ist für sie
attraktiv das versuchen wir auf unserem
sport zu übertragen
nichts währt fechten ist ein richtiger
sport wenn sie es mal ausprobieren
können werden sie sehen dass es nach
fünf minuten sehr anstrengend ist seine
leidenschaft für das lichtschwert
hechten gibt und ohne logo an andere
weiter als trainer sein verein ist einer
von mehr als 90 in ganz frankreich
insgesamt fechten schon rund 2000
franzosen mit dem lichtschwert
ich finde es toll werte zu vermitteln um
wie bei allen sportarten an erwachsene
und auch an jüngere man kann in star
wars universum eintauchen und
lichtschwert flechten basiert auf
kampfkunst und es ist wirklich eine
kunst so zu kämpfen
hier beim wettkampf hoffen alle dass
lichtschwert fechten wie traditionelles
fechten irgendwann olympisch wird
in frankreich gibt es immer mehr vereine
auch in europa sagen sich viele die
franzosen haben nicht schwert fechten
offiziell anerkannt warum nicht auch wir
der sport wird auf der ganzen welt
beliebt dieses mal ist antonino cohen
nur zweiter geworden doch medaillen sind
nicht so wichtig der lichtschwert
community geht es vielmehr darum dass
ihre leidenschaft auch andere ansteckt
genauso wie beim star wars figur
vor